when i really dug in late last year to
believe in this was actually because of
farmville on facebook was it natural for
you to believe in what's happening right
now with nfts because of the things like
farmville that happened on your platform
i've always been a pretty big believer
in virtual goods so i think from that
perspective yeah but i think a lot of
the the magic of nfts and a lot of the
web 3 work is that it's designed in a
way to be fundamentally interoperable so
i think that that's going to be really
important because it'll help break down
these silos between different apps and
make it so that all your stuff can be
more important between these different
experiences which i think increasingly
is what people are going to expect
here's the world we live in now you're a
young kid and you're in minecraft or
roblox you grow up and you want to go to
fortnight all that money you invested is
kind of stuck in there in the world that
you're talking about right now the
roblox and minecraft of the future when
you're done with that you're just going
to trade it for your fortnight stuff
you're going to trade the four night
stuff or sell it it's all going to be in
that one global ecosystem